the pandemic with masked mandates being
lifted in nearly every state the white
house is releasing a sweeping new plan
for the new normal the strategy is
designed to help americans live with the
virus and prepare for future outbreaks
this comes as covet cases decline and
businesses try to bounce back carter
evans has the story
it's very exciting because we get to see
each other's faces new york state lifted
its mass mandate for public schools
wednesday and california will follow
next week
it's about time they lift it los angeles
is set to drop its indoor mask mandate
friday for places like restaurants and
bars but some are cautious i'm going to
continue to wear a mask for my safety
it's still a contentious topic this was
florida's governor with a group of high
school students on wednesday you do not
have to wear those masks i mean please
take it
honestly it's not doing anything and we
got to stop with this theater so if you
want to wear it fine but this isn't this
is ridiculous
with covet cases plummeting nationwide
the biden administration's strategy is
an attempt to move the nation out of
crisis mode we've reached a new moment
in the fight against curved 19. the new
plan includes access to hundreds of
one-stop centers where americans can get
tested and treated with antiviral
medication if they test positive and a
promise to deliver updated vaccines and
treatments within 100 days of the
arrival of a new variant cbs news
contributor dr david agus is this the
right time for this kind of move no
question about it we have a good amount
of immunity in the united states so we
are ready to move to that next step if
you were diagnosed with cova 19 we can
give you a pill that can block serious
illness and hospitalization so we really
can enable us safely to go back to
dropping the masks and going back to a
more normal way of life
all rooting for that that was carter
evans reporting for us on the new normal
on the coveted front